e
e e
five there and five here well that's
good once they're over there they're
going to be able
to it being 10:00 I will call the fiscal
committee meeting to order on febru uh
January 30th 19 uh 2025
the first AR item is to elect the
officers as the chairman of the house
finance committee I am by law the
chairman of the the fiscal committee we
will look for a nomination for the vice
chair Senator Carson thank you thank you
Mr chairman I'd like to nominate Senator
Jim
Gray Motion in a second to nominate uh
Senator gray as the Vice chair of the
finance committee any other any other
nominations all in favor say I I oppose
no
second we will now um elect a clerk of
the fiscal
committee sen Senator representative
walner thank you Mr chair um I would
nominate uh representative F to be
clerk um
nomination for representative F to be
the clerk of the committee for the for
the next bium and a second further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I you are
elected further we have the adoption of
the fiscal committee rules and
procedures the legislative all right
well the really important thing is I
appoint Michael Caine to be the
legislative budget assistant for this
bium
with the approval of this committee all
in favor say I I oppose no he is
reelected okay then we go to the fiscal
committee rules and procedures I think
everybody's got it a onepage y
thing look for a motion to adopt those
rules for the bium
second move second Motion in a second
all in favor say
hi and and oppos no that is adopted we
also had an a motion from representative
F which I will recognize him to describe
it thank you Mr
chair so you hopefully all have it's one
page in front of you um and I think you
all understand what it's for basically
it will allow the um audits that come
before us to be automatically released
ahead of time so that not only we can
see them but our constituents can see
them and we can um get input from them
if they if they want to um give it to us
so we can then question POS POS those
questions to people that come before us
so that's basically it it'll it'll add
that to the rules and then it'll be a
permanent part of the
rules
question representative Edwards uh thank
you Mr chair uh and thank you for taking
my question representative I I I just am
trying I agree with the concept I just
want to make sure I'm I'm reading the
semantics and the timing of this it it
says all audits will be accepted
skipping ahead upon inclusion on the
fiscal committee agenda I I the the
trigger to accepting an audit I thought
was an action by the fiscal committee
not merely placing it on AG an agenda is
is that terminology the way you want it
so that's what we're changing rather
than having to wait for the fiscal
committee committee to see it and
approve it this is basically saying as
soon as it goes on to the fiscal
committee agenda it'll be put on to the
website release to the public release to
us and there'll be no further motions
necessary to release it after we have
even after we hear the report from the
Auditors
followup do go ahead have we ever
rejected an audit uh do you know
representa walner and I couldn't
remember any in our many years of
experience I don't think anybody else is
okay then I'm I'm fine with the language
I
just it saves the clerk from having to
make that lengthy thing I I make the
motion that we accept the report place
it on file and release in the usual
minut Senator gray um this fits in with
another thing that I want to try to
accomplish and that is getting people to
use a tablet to get the bulk of this
material so that the clerks don't have
to go do that this is one of my first
days I've got the agenda up on my tablet
here and I'm going to try to use the
links that are in that uh just like
representative Earth does here uh we can
save some money if we can get everybody
to do it that way uh but I'm understand
that they probably won't get everybody
but even even even getting most of us
you know could be helpful a lot of heavy
lifting and having these audits on being
able to be put into the agenda and not
just paper copies in your book is a
furtherance towards that so I am in
favor of this will you second very
good did you second it yes very good
further discussion on amendment
five seeing none all in favor say I I
oppose no a second motion that it be uh
we accept this amendment to the rules
that we've already the rules as amended
rules as amended we'll vote now on the
rules as amended with amendment five
further discussion seeing none all in
favor say I I oppose no okay that
amendment is
adopted and we'll be moving on to the
regular
agenda acceptance uh tab two is
acceptance of the
minutes of November 15 2024 the last
meeting of Mo to
approve motion by Senator Gray second
by second
second second by Senator representative
Edwards is there any additions or
Corrections seeing none all in favor of
the motion say I I oppose no the minutes
are adopted yes
abstain and those who were not present
at that have abstain yes three of them
Senator Carlson Senator Rosenwald
Ben Waters
okay we have a consent calendar for tabs
4 through
8 um there are some bills that have been
removed at uh representative Edwards
asked to
remove under tab six item
[Music]
25004 and I also would make the uh
notice that under that name tab six item
25016 has been withdrawn by the
Department of
Education under Tab
7 uh representative F
removed
257 are there any further ones that the
Senate wishes
removed this one is also pull and
25001 was also removed on under Tab
four okay and did I me I did mention
that 25016 was
withdrawn anything further to come off
consent move to approve the consent
calendar as
amended motion by Senator gray second by
Senator Rosenwald to approve the consent
calendar with the
aforementioned changes any fur further
discussion all in favor say I I oppose
no we have adopted the consent
calendar Senator
Rosen okay so we're moving on to tab
eight Tab four oh wait let's go let's go
to the ones that have been removed under
Tab
four or rather under tab six six 25004
what about tap 4001 didn't you say you
Tak something off tap four that was
removed was removed oh that's how you by
the department yes all right no and we
have the Department of Health and Human
Services here uh to address the
item representative Edwards is
recognized for a question on
25004 okay uh thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question uh this
this is uh related to um a great program
uh where we gather information from our
population and I am curious if uh the
the collection of personal data around
this program whether it's done on an
optin or an opt out
basis good morning good morning Ian watt
I'm the director for the division of
Public Health Services thank you for
your question representative Edwards so
the there is an RSA uh 13210 - A which
requires uh newborn screening for any
child born in New Hampshire that same
statute uh 13210 DC uh does allow for an
opt out for parents who may not want to
have their their children participate so
it's it's a a mandatory program with an
opt out uh should parents not want to
participate so so to say that a little
differently it it it's designed as an uh
an opt out program and the default
assumption is that everyone has opted in
until they opt out that's correct and
and the reason we do this screening just
by example uh we test for or baby's born
in New Hampshire tested for a series of
potential hereditary disorders some of
these disorders by example may be
something like uh a children is not able
a child's not able to absorb fats so
it's really critical that you test that
in the first 24 to 48 hours you wouldn't
be able to see the effects of these
conditions none of them have any any
visible symptoms you would have what
looks like a very healthy baby with a
condition that may not be detectable and
may cause extreme Health outcomes or
even death if not treated and addressed
uh addressed quickly for example if if
you contined feeding breast milk or
regular formula formula to that child uh
they may have fairly dire Health
outcomes or or death one one more
followup follow well I I would like to
this is one of many programs it seems
that the department runs that are set up
on a default of requiring people to opt
out in order to avoid the data
collection and um and I and I understand
the desire um to do it that way but uh
in the coming next year and during my my
bill preparation I I'm going to look at
um U
mandatory uh optins for every data
collection and I'd like to be able to
talk to you about the various programs
that you have so that we can review them
and and do what makes sense happy to
discuss that thank you all right thank
you let attain a to adopt the
item question from Senator Rosen yes
thank you could you tell us please what
the op out rate or the rate of babies
newborns getting the screening is yep
and then thank you for your question
Senator Rosenwald in 2023 99.2% of all
newborns in New Hampshire were screened
by dried blood spot so we had a less
than 1% opt out rate in
2023 second Edwards moves to accept item
25004 Senator gray excuse me Senator
gray seconds is there any further
discussion on the item seeing none are
you ready for the question all in favor
say I I I oppose no the item is adopted
moving on to Tab
S and item
25007 again Health and Human Services
representative f is recognized for a
question uh thank you Mr chair thank you
for being before us so my understanding
is that the only thing that's remaining
I guess in this being funded with this
the last part of this grant are the
community health workers and my question
is are any of these community health
workers Co collocated in school in our
Public
Schools thank you for your question no
none of the community health workers
will be working in schools they work
based out of largely Family Resource
Centers they work with our public health
networks and then a few other
health-based facilities thank
you repres representative Edwards for a
question uh thank you Mr chair this is
this is a kind of a related topic but
not directly applicable um on the
DHHS uh HR website there's a statement
DHHS also has many positions that are
eligible for telework and um with the uh
current national Focus on getting um
government employees back into the
offices I I'm just curious to the extent
to which uh
DHHS uh may need to go back through
those positions eligible for Tork and
and just validate or
revalidate that um teleworking is is the
appropriate um solution for for the good
of the taxpayer sure so the Department
of Health and Human Services we follow
theate Statewide policy on Tork um and
and our policies and procedures are
consistent with that and and we've been
engaging in Tork for some time um we
have seen the uh the the national um
indications at the at at the federal
level um but but ultimately at this
point in time we are following the state
procedures and policies that are in
place uh thank
you further questions further discussion
Representative no just move to approve
okay move to approve second motion by
representative Earth second by Senator
gray to adopt item
25007 is there any further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question all in favor say I I oppose no
the item is adopted we'll move on to the
regular calendar under tab
nine Department of administrative
services and I think we all understand
what's happening and everybody read the
item there is a request to extend the
cfer release Rel release
date till August till March 31st of this
year so everyone understand what what
the reasoning is and we the Mr Cain will
try to make sure that we don't go astray
on any of the numbers that might have uh
resulted from this it will be up to to
date pretty much on all the other
numbers but official the official
release of the numbers for the end of
the fiscal year 24 won't take
place till a later date in this case
March 31st normally it would be January
1st I'll entertain a motion to approve
and Senator gray moves to approve the
item second by is that Senator bsel Ros
senator rosenal sorry I heard it from
that side but I wasn't
looking further discussion seeing none
all in favor say I I oppose no that
motion is adopted the cafa will be
released on 3:31 we hope no
later item 10 oh it's Tab 10 item is
258 from Department of Fish and
Game are there questions on the
item representative leash leean moves to
approve Senator BD Senator birdell
seconds any further discussion seeing
none are you all are you ready for the
vote all in favor say I I oppose no
we've adopted
25008 tab 11
move to approve is the winter
maintenance uh motion winter M winter
maintenance
funding Senator Bell moves to approve
second Senator Grace seconds is any
question what's that senator rosemal for
a question is somebody here Department
yeah of the
department question from Department of
Transportation
and please introduce yourself and make
sure the microphones are turned
on good morning I'm Danielle Shandon
name the Director of Finance for
do alen ham the state uh maintenance
engineer for do thank you Senator Ros
just simply do you expect that this is
the only request you'll be making or
or are you planning on coming back this
fiscal
year um that that depends entirely on on
uh the winter that's ahead of us that
we're not aware of there's uh several
storms predicted over the next 10 days
and and winter goes on for a while
longer um on average this would not be
an adequate transfer to get us through
the end of the year so would not be
would not be okay you could you could
expect that that uh a storm uh a small
storm would cost in excess of a million
dollars so if you look at that if if you
look at that um number it wouldn't take
many storms to hit the 5.7 million that
we're asking for here thank
you further from the committee several
of us were discussing the fact that we
were coming to work behind a plow that
was driving along with on a dry Road and
and rarely put down the blade so we're
wondering how prevalent that is and
whether there's a savings and when they
decide when to send out the plows and do
someone looked at the road before or is
that person driving the plow the one
that decides whether any plowing is
needed um thank you for the question um
there there's um a patrol Foreman in in
charge of the crew and there's a mean a
supervisor in charge of the foreman um
that generally put eyes on the road um
this morning it likely more likely was
um clean up clean up the the shoulder
and the snowbank along the edge of the
road more than anything they they may
have been called out at 4:00 a.m. for
conditions so
um U so that that's most likely what
you're seeing today was just clean up
after yesterday's storm thank you
Senator rosenal anything further your
lights on oh I'm we had a motion in a
second all right right motion or second
to approve any further discussion seeing
none all in favor say I I oppose no the
mo that uh motion is adopted
2533 all
right tab 12 two items the first one
25023 judicial
councel move to approve Senator gray
moves to
approve second
by Senator
birdell further discussion seeing none
all in favor say I I I'll oppose no the
motion is to approve and it is
adopted moving on to item
25024 same tab second Senator grey moov
approve Senator Carson seconds to
approve 25024 any further discussion
seeing none
all in favor say I I oppose
no that item is
adopted moving on to tab
25009 the office of legislative budget
assistant we need need to move some
money as it's going to be a a place
we're all going to move to after
July any further discussion on that item
move to proove Senator gry moves to appr
approve Senator birdell
seconds is there any further discussion
seeing none all in favor say I I oppose
no that motion is
adopted the rest of the items are for
information does anybody wish to have
any discussion Senator rosenell thank
you I did have a few questions on the
Health and Human Services is
dashboard okay the dashboard for Health
and Human
Services all right that what's the item
oh it is
2511 sort of in the middle of the pack
all right
25 does she have a question okay 01
011 Senator Rosen wal is recogn thank
you my first question is on table
six why um are the senu youth center
statistics
only through
November uh good morning my name is
Patricia Tilly I'm an associate
commissioner here at the Department of
Health and Human Services thank you
Senator Rosenwald when we submitted this
we had not yet finished the end of the
month of December when we had submitted
the dashboard okay and thank you and if
I could follow followup question second
question is on the next page the aid to
the um permanently and totally disabled
case loads continue to
decrease and I'm wondering is it because
we have fewer people who are permanently
and totally disabled under State's
definition or their over income or why
are we seeing those case loads
decrease I'm going to defer to Nathan if
he has an answer if not I'll follow up I
I I I think ultimately I need to go back
and talk to Alissa Hardy today to
understand the full Trend there is a
data error though um that you will see
in the aps clients line that says five
that should be 333 for the month of
November um but I can talk to Melissa
Hardy and Chris sanello see if there's
more larger systematic trends that
they're seeing and what are the causes
of that that would be great and my final
question is on the next page the
Community Mental Health Cent case loads
um this committee was told that by
September 1st of last year we would have
accurate case loow data so I my question
is is this case load data now accurate
uh thank you no it is not yet accurate
there are two Community Mental Health
Centers who are going through EHR
conversions and when that is and that
has taken longer than planned and so
when that is complete we will go back
and fix the data going backwards you
know when that will do they have been
working on it full they they're working
on it Full Tilt thank you thank you Mr
chair thank you Senator rosemal any
further questions on the item
representative
Edwards thank you Mr chair I I noticed
the the positive trend with the uh cunu
Youth Development Center the census is
staying you know low um I I had um asked
a few months ago for um a presentation
or a briefing or a conversation or
however you want to call it on how uh
what the explicit mechanisms are for
being aware of the census and
anticipating um what kind of actions may
be necessary in terms of of um uh
transferring people to different
locations and the like I I'm still
looking forward to that conversation do
are you aware that we're developing that
that that presentation it's it's going
to be more relevant for the new center
than our existing Center but I'm sure
the methods are very very similar we are
currently working with courts and law
enforcement around how we're going to
address especially when we have
constraints in the new facility that we
will have a um we we will need to
maintain that low it's enrollment so we
are working on that we're working with
those Partners to give you those
explicit answers I'm going to talk at a
very high level about it this afternoon
I won't be going into too much detail
other than to acknowledge that the
census has been going in the right
direction and yet um we know we need to
be prepared for the um potential for
when we're in a new facility and we're
much more constrained how we will make
sure that we stay below the numbers that
are expected okay I well good I'm I'm
glad I'm glad you're working on it and
coordinating it with the community I
just when you're ready I'd really like
to know thank you
further discussion on the
dashboard seeing none of there any other
items on information that anybody wishes
discussion
for representative
Lehman thank you Mr chairman I was just
had a couple of questions on item U 38
the Youth Development
Center
claims okay do we have anybody to
represent that
anybody from attorney general or I don't
see y
okay have the whole office
MH representative Lehman for a question
thank you Mr
chairman so uh in the letter that we
received from the former Chief Justice
he points out that we need an efficient
Fair resolution to these potential
claims um
yesterday representative wer and I heard
from the uh judicial branch that this
has been a daunting task to get these
claims through and get them resolved in
a timely manner and there are hundreds
more still out there to be decided by
the
court um however the judicial branch has
been asked for a 4% cut um to try to
meet the budget deficits that we're
facing so I'm kind of concerned that
we're hearing from the judicial branch
which I have a great respect for that um
they're looking at potentially a 4% cut
in their budget and whether what you've
see seen from the court already have you
seen any sort
of slow up in cases because of the
volume and if so to me it would appear
that by suggesting the courts take a 4%
cut it may actually impact the
efficiency of handling these cases so
I'm just kind of curious are you seeing
things move fairly quickly or as far as
the resolution of the cases before the
court
it it sounds like your question is is
directed towards the case sure and and
sure Jen Foley general counsel for the
YDC um settlement fund um it sounds like
your question is about um cases pending
in court um and how quickly those are
moving um I can certainly that's a feir
yeah okay I can address with respect to
how quickly um the claims moving in the
settlement process but the with respect
to uh the litigation I would defer to
the Attorney General's
office hi I'm Laura Raymond from the
Attorney General's office working uh on
the YDC claim fund um I also similarly
to attorney Foley um am not involved
day-to-day in the litigation matters and
rather am focused on the claim fund but
it's my understanding um that any
potential proposed um budgetary cuts to
the judicial branch are not having uh at
least a current impact on the status of
the litigated matters relating to YDC in
court um any more than um the other
factors uh that would affect the pace of
those cases not including of course the
volume but that the budget itself is not
having a specific impact at this point
followup Mr chairman thank you so I
guess in division one we haven't seen
any presentation yet as far as the
justice department that I'm aware of as
far as the budget are are you being
saddled with an unfair burden with
trying to handle all these cases I know
you like the court the court hasn't seen
any increase in staff and I don't
believe you've asked for any significant
increase in staff to handle this
mounting claim
process uh thank you for the question
representative
I we're we are presenting next we're
presenting next week so just just as a
heads up on that so we will be
presenting on our budget and our
operations
I don't think I would not say that we're
experiencing an unfair burden I mean
this is the
YDC cases RIT large are quite an
undertaking for both the Judiciary and
our office and and the settlement fund
process that that's for sure but we we
have been utilizing a combination of
in-office resources and outside Council
to handle the YDC
litigation the spending on that has been
pretty consistent for the last few years
and so we are handling it it it's hard
work and people are working hard but I
wouldn't describe the burden as unfair
and and I think we're prepared to
continue handling the work with the
budget that I anticipate will be put
before you that said I can't get out in
front of Governor aot she hasn't
presented her her budget yet so I would
I I don't want to get out in front of
her on that but I don't anticipate
issues on that front that said I just
want to give a shout out to the team and
to the administrator's office because
people are working very hard and we're
endeavoring to utilize resources as
efficiently as we can so it's hard work
but I wouldn't describe it as an unfair
burden by any means all right thanks
thanks Mr chairman make it clear the uh
honorable bradrick and his staff are on
your budget not the court budget until
those cases get to court is that
correct the the the the settlement fund
dollars are technically yes appropriated
to the Department of Justice we
reimburse the judicial branch for any
costs that the administrator's office um
has so that that's technically correct
but the employees of the settlement
front process are technically employees
of the judicial branch so it's a little
bit of a unique Arrangement so the money
is appropriated to us so I would say
they are technically on our budget
because that fund is appropriated to the
doj but that's that the settlement fund
though is is separate I would say from
our
regular ongoing operating budget thank
you do you mind if I add just a little
bit of color to that uh so the fund
itself um uh pays for uh the the costs
of the administration so the
administrator broad's office and staff
and Consultants that is essentially
build to the fund and the Attorney
General's office is the one who um
essentially cuts the checks for those
costs um in addition to that um the
department of justice under the statute
um to the extent that there's some
extraordinary costs beyond their typical
budget um is also paid for under the
fund um and so the administrator and
general formela work closely together on
on watching the just the costs of
administering the claims in addition to
um the awards and that are paid out from
the fund
itself if there's anything we can do in
the legislature please let us know uh
this is a big effect on the entire
budget we may be able to put some
something in perhaps another limit into
hb2 um we're happy to entertain some
limit to to what can be recovered rather
than these ridiculous uh multi-million
dollar settlements that we see they
don't seem to make any sense so if you
want us to put any further limits we're
happy to include that in
hb2 Senator Rosal thank you so it seems
like you've got 600 or so pending claims
and the average payout is around
$500,000 if you if we continue on that
trajectory of average payout and I guess
part of my question is do you think we
will that seems to me like we're looking
at a $300 million total exposure going
forward
about is my math
right start okay I'll take the first
shot at that and I will let attorney
Raymond also add add her
thoughts I guess Senator I would start
by saying I can't argue with your math
if we were to
go I I am a lawyer so I try never to
argue on the math front but um yeah the
average to this point has been about
$500,000 per resolution and and if you
were to multiply that by the pending
claims you would you would get the
number that that you just mentioned that
said I I
think as we go through the
claims it would be I think a mistake to
make any assumptions about where the
average resolution is is going to be it
could go down it it could go up um it it
just it really depends on on whether as
we get further into the claims that have
been filed we start to see less
meritorious claims or more meritorious
claims it it's difficult to make a
assumptions so I I would just caution on
that but if the average were to hold at
500,000 you can just multiply that by by
the number of claims that come in but I
based on what we have seen so far I
don't think we should assume that all of
the claims to come will look like the
claims that have been resolved to this
point they may
not as as you go forward and prosecute
the abusive forces
are we seeing a pattern there's so many
of them that claim both physical and
sexual
abuse is are we seeing a pattern is
there an exaggeration here over some of
these things on the people you you're
Prosecuting that that supposedly did the
abuse what what kind of numbers are you
seeing relative to the numbers that are
being accused of I mean these people
would have to spend hours every day
doing sexual abuse to see the numbers
that we see does doesn't jive in my
mind yeah I'm I'm a little bit Limited
in the detail I can go into on on that
but but I will say this based on what
I've seen in the criminal investigation
over the last three to four years and
based on what we have seen come through
the claims fund so far um I
I I am not surprised let me say it this
way by what we've seen in in the claims
fund because we've seen a lot of similar
allegations in the claims fund to what
we saw during the criminal investigation
and while we only bring we can only
bring criminal charges when we think we
can prove a case Beyond a reasonable
doubt that doesn't mean we haven't seen
a lot more allegations across the
decades that we may not have brought
criminal charges for so so far with the
240 two claims I believe that have been
resolved when I compare what we saw in
those claims to everything thing I've
seen in the criminal investigation I
think the best the best way for me to
phrase it is I'm not surprised by what
we've seen there it seemed there there
is enough consistency between those two
groups that I'm not surprised beyond
that it's difficult for me to go into
much more detail and I would also just
again caution that there are a lot of
claims that will come into the claims
fund that we may not have even seen on
the criminal side yet and so I just
caution against making any assumptions
about the hundreds of claims to come and
what those will look like thank you
further from the
committee seeing none thank you for the
update if we're done with the regular
fiscal agenda we'll move on to the
audits
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the
committee for the record I'm Christine
Young director of audits for the
LBA uh as you know we contract with with
KPMG to conduct the audit of the
turnpike system uh joining us is Bob
Mahoney partner from KPMG he will
present the report and also joining us
is Danielle Shand D the Director of
Finance for
do and with that I will go ahead and
turn it over to Bob for the presentation
of the
report great thanks Christine good
morning uh So within your materials uh
you'll see three reports um I will cover
each of those and then I will go through
the required Communications uh to the
committee under the auditing standards
so the first report in your materials is
the annual financial report of the
turnpike system and within that report
is our audit opinion uh which we issued
on December 23rd
2024 that uh audit opinion is an
unmodified opinion so also known as a
clean opinion um within that opin
opinion it indicates that we conducted
our audit in accordance with generally
accepted auditing standards as well as
Government auditing standards and it
also indicates that management is
ultimately responsible for the accuracy
of the financial statements and we are
responsible for expressing an opinion on
the financial
statements in addition uh that opinion
also references uh what is known as a
yellow book report which is the another
report within your materials um also
known as the report on internal control
over financial reporting and compliance
in other matters and within that report
um there were no significant
deficiencies or material weaknesses um
that we identified during the course of
the turnpike audit and then lastly uh
the third report in your materials is
the debt compliance report um and that
report indicates that uh the turnpike is
in compliance with the provisions and
Covenants of the bond
resolutions um so all all good news to
report with respect to to um the audit
report reports uh and with that I will
go through the uh required
Communications as well under the
auditing standards so during the course
of the audit we did not identify any
significant unusual
transactions um we did identify one
uncorrected audit misstatement which uh
is consistent with prior years related
to The Trusted other post-employment
benefit plan um which is not the
liability is not recorded in the uh
Turnpike statements which is consistent
with the other Enterprise funds as as
well we did not identify any corrected
misstatements during the course of the
audit uh in addition um we did discuss
uh the significant accounting policies
uh with management during the course of
the audit and determin that they were
reasonable in addition uh we did
evaluate um accounting estimates during
the course of the audit and we also
determined those to be reasonable um
there were no sub subsequent events
identified there were no illegal Acts or
fraud that we identified during the
course of the audit uh there were no
non-compliance with laws or regulations
uh no disagreements with management uh
we were not aware of any consultation
with other
accountants um and it we did not um have
any difficult uh encounters or
situations um that required us to
consult you know internally um either um
and lastly there are written
Communications which include the
engagement letter as well as the
management representation letter on file
with management and uh we are in
dependent with respect to the turnpike
um as of uh December 23rd so uh with
that happy to answer any questions you
may
have statement from finance
officer good morning um yes uh
we we are happy to have a clean opinion
um that's everything that we hope for
that's what we work towards you know I I
do want to thank my staff uh we have in
finance experienced quite a bit of
turbulence uh we had a f about a 45%
turnover rate and um so the staff that
are doing this were relatively new it
took uh they did a great job I will say
that they did a great job and I I just
wanted to thank them and thank Bob and
uh Christine for their help as well on
behalf of the committee we congratulate
you on your good work thank you
representative
earth oh we don't need to do any
approvals we're good because we did that
took that vote earlier we already okay
very good all right next group Next
audit
I see Smiles that's
good okay the next presentation will be
for the audit of the Lottery Commission
financial statements and uh this audit
was performed by our office uh with me
is Jean Mitchell she's the financial
audit supervisor from our office who
supervised the audit that our senior
manager Kimberly Bisson was responsible
for managing uh Kimberly is presenting
the next audit so we're trying to
allocate responsibilities here uh and
joining us from the Lottery Commission
is Charlie McIntyre executive director
and Jim durus Chief Financial Officer
who will be available for questions and
uh with that I will turn it over to Jean
for the presentation yes you have
audited the department that sees the
most audits
of
all good morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee uh my name is Jean
Mitchell and we're here today to report
the results of our audit of the
financial statements contained in New
Hampshire Lottery's annual comprehensive
financial report for the fiscal year
ended June 30
2024 the financial statements begin on
page 48 of the Lottery
aaer lottery management is responsible
for the preparation and fair
presentation the financial statements in
accordance with generally accepted
accounting
principles our Auditor's report and
opinion dated December 23rd 2024 can be
found on pages 29 through 32 of the
financial section of the
report as noted in the opinion paragraph
on page 29 we issued an unmodified or
clean opinion on the lottery
commission's basic financial statements
which also includes the notes and and
other supplementary
information while our opinion speaks
directly to the financial statements and
notes no matters came to our attention
that caused us to believe that the other
information in the financial section of
the report was inconsistent with the
basic financial
statements auditing standards require
that we make a number of disclosures to
you these disclosures are similar to the
disclosures discussed by KPMG for the
turnpike's audit we included our
required disclosures as an insert in
your copy of the
report in the interest of time I will
not go through each of them
individually however we can say that we
are satisfied with the cooperation of
the lottery staff in the progress of the
audit and there is nothing that we need
to bring to the committee's attention
related to any concerns with the
required
disclosures in accordance with
government auditing standards we will
issue report on our consideration of the
lotteries commission internal control
over financial reporting and on compt
cents in other matters as a bypro
product of the audit of the financial
statements the report will be included
in the management letter which will be
be presented to the fiscal committee at
a future
meeting this concludes my presentation
I'd like to thank the Lottery Commission
management and staff for their
assistance during the audit with your
permission Mr chairman I will turn the
presentation over to director McIntyre
who can provide management perspective
on the lottery and on their report thank
you very much
good morning Mr chairman members of the
fiscal committee I'm Charlie McIntyre
have the privilege of being the director
of the New Hampshire lottery I initially
want to thank the folks at the lb audit
staff uh Jean and Kimberly who we spent
a lot of time with uh for their hard
work uh and then also I want to thank
the finance staff and particularly our
CFO Jim duris uh when I started in the
lottery our transfer was 62 million in
fy11 last year was 207 million um you
don't grow 3x without effort and time
and commitment and to continually have a
clean audit every time despite the
number of vertical we've attained is a
is a testament to the folks that I get
to work with including our CFO duris and
so uh with that I'd like to open up any
questions the committee may have for us
conratulations to you and your finance
officer and and I know uh Miss Mitchell
rarely misses anything so you're both
doing very well questions from the
committee representative Lehman thank
you Mr chairman maybe not a uh question
Charlie but just thank you uh your
revenues have always been impressive and
I think they went up about 5% from 23 to
24 and uh if you could rub off on some
of our
other agencies but no thank you for your
work and what you've done thanks I
appreciate that repres lean I'm
certainly um it's a Testament of the
folks I get to work with um as I recall
I think we were 47 million over plan
last year which is I would suggest you
better than good
so we have an amazing team they'll
really need that money for the next two
years as well we're having Great
Hopes further from the committee all
right understand we've already accepted
the report and placed it on file yes
thank you very much good work thank you
this one okay yes right here in the
middle oh
okay okay and for the last audit of the
day we'd like to present our assessment
of the internal controls in place over
the revenues and expenditures processed
at the department of Information
Technology uh this audit was performed
by our office uh Kimberly Bon senior
manager with our office was the InCharge
manager on the audit and uh she will
present the report and joining us from
doit is Dennis goule commissioner of the
department and uh he'll be available for
questions as well and now I'll turn it
over to Kimberly for the
presentation good morning Mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Kimberly Bisson and
I'll be presenting the report on our
assessment of the internal controls in
place over the receipt deposit recording
and reporting of the Department of
information Technology's revenues and
the authorization payment recording and
reporting of its expenditures during the
N9 months ended March 31st
2024 if you turn to the table of
contents you will see that the report
contains 14 comments and recommendations
two of which suggest legislative action
may be required audity responses were
prepared by the department as well as
the department of
administrative Services Who provided
responses for observation numbers 3 five
and
8 a recommendation summary is provided
on page three and background information
is included on page seven on page 10 you
will find a summary of the Department's
revenues and expenditures for the nine
months ended March 31st
2024 our objectives scope and
methodology are described on page
12 in the interest of time I won't cover
the background information and I'll go
right into our audit objective and the
results of the
audit we conducted this performance
audit in accordance with government
auditing standards the objective of the
audit was to evaluate whether the
department had designed implemented and
operated suitable internal controls over
the receipt deposit recording and
reporting of its revenues and the
authorization payments recording and
reporting of its expenditures during the
9 months ended March 31st
2024 as reported in the executive
summary beginning on page one we found
the department has not established
adequate internal controls over its
revenues and expenditures we found
certain Financial Accounting processes
were overly complex outdated
insufficiently documented lacked
oversight or did not fully comply with
state
law the Department's control and
environment continues to be impacted
from its failure to fully resolve all
comments from the 2018 performance audit
and the
2016 I'm sorry excuse me 2006 Financial
audit of the office of Information
Technology the observations begin on
page
14 observation number one notes that the
department has not imple implemented
sufficient controls over the cost
allocation process the department did
not maintain an updated cost allocation
methodology listing nor a sufficient
description of the mechanics behind the
cost allocation process and was
ultimately unable to provide a
recalculation of the cost allocations
performed by its cap 95 system for three
out of 45 items selected for review the
observation recommends a department
establish comprehensive and documented
policies and procedures for all cost
allocation financial accounting and
Reporting activities and also notes that
management should be able to calculate
and substantiate all costs invoiced to
its user
agencies did you want to ask a question
now representative Edward had a question
thank you Mr chair as long as the topic
is up I I i' I've I've read the
recommendation uh and the background
what what I'm missing is is a little bit
of the the so what factor um of course
we want to do proper cost allocation but
in in the absence of of good reliable
repeatable cost allocation is the state
losing any money or is this really about
arguing of who who picks up the check at
dinner I I they're recouping all the
costs but it's just more of are the
agencies being ACC accurately charged
so we're able we were unable to
recalculate some of those elction so it
therefore you can't be entirely certain
that the amount charged each agency
maybe it was too much maybe it was too
little maybe some of those costs should
have been allocated to another one but
it's all internal to the state this cost
allocation isn't reaching out to
external third parties and it's not
costing the state additional money it's
just a poor methodology is what I'm
hearing correct is yes okay thank
you
um um on page 17 observation number two
recommends that the department expand
accounts payable policies and procedures
to ensure invoices paid or in compliance
with significant contract payment
Provisions the observation also
recommends that the department perform a
monthly reconciliation of the New
Hampshire first detail transaction
register to supporting documentation as
required by state
policy moving on to page 19 observation
number three recommends the department
establish policies and procedures for
assigning activity codes in New
Hampshire first for use and tracking
expenditures and employee Time by user
agency the policy should include a
comprehensive and descriptive listing of
the activity codes available for use or
specify the process to follow when the
choice of activity code is
unclear the observation also recommends
that the department of administrative
Services consider implementing a
security check to limit access to
activity codes within the time
management module similar to those used
by other New Hampshire first modules if
feasible observation number four on page
21 identified SE segregation of Duties
weaknesses within the Department's
request and requisition system and
recommends that the department review
the assignment of authorities within the
system to ensure employee approval
authorities are compatible and limited
to only those individuals requiring
access it also recommends a department
perform a periodic review of r and our
system
authorities continuing on to page 22
observation number five noted that the
internal controls related to the
Department's telecommunication process
exhibited weaknesses that impacted its
ability to process telecommunications
revenues accurately efficiently and
timely the observation recommends the
department establish policies and
procedures governing the
Telecommunications process and adopt a
comprehensive manual to conform with
statute the observation also recommends
the department ensure Duties are
appropriately segregated document the
basis for sear charges build to
customers and publish a comprehensive
fee
schedule Additionally the department
should consider documenting the review
and approval of invoice batches in New
Hampshire first and consult with Das
regarding the feasibility of
establishing an audit trail of invoice
batch approvals
observation number six on page
24 recommends that the department
strengthen controls over salaries and
benefits monitoring and review process
and also document the processes through
written policies and
procedures the department should also
develop document and Implement policies
and procedures covering employee
termination payouts to include a review
and approval by the appropriate level of
management question
thank you Mr chair um so the numbering
of these observations with this being
six number six is that meant to imply um
you what you think the priority for
fixes ought to be or is this just a a r
kind of more of a random numbering of
observations um we or ordered the
observations in terms
of the most impactful so like the ones
that we thought thought were most
important in order and so on down all
right this one reads to me like it may
be the most important but but okay thank
you I think um with the
telecommunication expend uh revenues and
expenditures um
they're less than the total doit
revenues and expenditures so there are
some
you did I I defer to your judgment you
you guys do this for living I I just do
this as a hobby so thank you yeah
okay you on number six actually you just
finished number six I believe okay
sorry
um on page 26 observation number 7
recommends that the department establish
and document a formal risk assessment M
process for recognizing evaluating and
responding to risks that could affect
its ability to reach its financial
accounting and Reporting objectives the
process should include an IT security
risk assessment to ensure its
information assets are adequately
considered it also recommends the
department routinely review and
periodically test its continuity of
operations plans to ensure they remain
reliable and
practical observ number eight discusses
the lack sorry we're on page 28
discusses the lack of a consistent audit
Trail to evidence the review and
approval of invoice batches in New
Hampshire first and is also directed
toward the department of administrative
Services the observation recommends that
Das consider whether it should take
steps to implement an effective audit
Trail for the review and approval of
invoice batches within New Hampshire
first and also recommends that doit
Implement policies and procedures to
evidence review and approval of
telecommunications invoices prior to
their release in New Hampshire first and
posting to Department
accounts you get closer the
M can you hear me now better better okay
you were trailing off okay
sorry observation number nine on page 29
recommends that the department test its
backup process at least annually as
outlined in its contingency
planning
policy um turning to page 30 observation
number 10 recommends that the department
prioritize the results of Prior audit
findings resulting from the 2018
performance audit and the 2006 Financial
audit of the office of Information
Technology and create a corrective
action plan for resolution as soon as
possible just a question just a comment
on that one uh I have been in
Communications with the governor's
office through the LBA about this it's a
an ongoing thing it's something that
I've complained about through the system
uh on other audits that there is not
sufficient tracking of the audit
findings so that we know how they're
being done what they're being done and
I'm told that Mr James Gary from the
governor's office will be the one in
charge not only of of these it audit
items but for the whole system to make
sure that there is progress being made
on those audit findings because it
repeating and repeating and repeating
these you know some of the most
egregious go back to
2006 and haven't been resolved but we've
been talking about them the staff that
involved in this I know that that the
people up here at this table are cheap
uh you know but the staff uh time that
it takes to repeat these is is
tremendous so we need to get them
resolved and put the attention that
needs to happen on to them thank you
thank
you um on page 32 observation number 11
question from Senator Waters thank you
Mr chairman on that on that same item on
number 10 that first reference to the uh
2006 audit I mean it takes me back to
Observation number one where we have
Department Ms that are under great
stress trying to complete their budgets
and not knowing whether they can rely on
the figures that they're supposed to
allocate for their technology and and
observation number one it says that it's
an ongoing process so there's is there
any assurance that agencies can actually
depend on the accuracy of what they're
being build or is that it's going to
still unfold over time
is that yeah okay sorry um during that
review of the costs that were allocated
to the agencies um it's very involved so
um costs that were allocated
using one method we found that those
were allocated correctly we were able to
recalculate them and determine that they
were accurate um where it gets more
complicated is when the system allocates
costs using a method within a method so
then you have to take one
method um use that and the other method
and allocate those costs and that's
where we found the struggle where we
weren't able to fully recalculate those
costs and the cap 95 system is doing
that
um so for what we found it was three out
of 45 so for the vast for the majority
of them we were confident in that those
costs were allocated properly but for a
small piece of them it would be harder
to determine
question do you have any sense of how
far off the errors may be are we talking
about large variations potentially or
relatively small ones it wasn't
necessarily that there were errors it's
just that we couldn't get an
understanding of how the system was
calculating allocating those costs so we
couldn't recalculate it so it could very
well be accurate but we just couldn't
determine that because we couldn't
get a good understanding of the process
to do the calculation so I understand
that so does that mean that you really
have no idea how far off they could be
for those particular ones correct and
those particular ones are particularly
significant sorry I can continue
um I don't have in I I don't have in
front of me right now I could find that
information for you but I don't I have
that information right at this moment I
think it'd be really helpful if we get
an order of magnitude idea of how
serious these problems are are um
especially they go back for whatever um
decades if that's possible okay um
commissioner goule I think will address
that um in his comments he's
saying
okay
um I think I'm on oh thank
you sorry uh on page 32 observation
number 11 recommends the adoption of
administrative rules as required by
Statute if the department deems
administrative rules unnecessary
statutory rision should be
requested on page 33 observation number
12 recommends the department seek to
amend statute to clarify unclassified
position titles and ensure division
directors are being compensated
correctly and also to consult with Das
to determine if F further statutory
revision regarding its 10th unclassified
position is necessary the department
should also seek clarification from TS
or the Attorney General to determine
whether employees working a 40-hour week
are properly
classified question is this is this uh
thank thank you for taking the question
is observation 12 really tightly related
to Observation six or is it is this just
uh Bas basically a specific example of
the problem that six presents
observation six had to do with
monitoring of the payroll so more with
um monitoring of the bi-weekly payroll
process and and the cost and observation
number 12 has to do with um the
department has some unclassified
positions that aren't clearly defined in
the statute like it will just say
director versus the specific director so
observation 12 is really aimed at
um being more clear in the statute so
that we can be able to determine that a
specific division director's pay was
accurate so all right uh well thank you
these these Personnel issues to me get
to be very significant just for the
faith and integrity of the
system okay on page 36 observation
number 30 um 13 notes that the
department dep did not complete timely
performance evaluations for 60% of the
employees selected for review it
recommends that the department comply
with statute and administrative Rule and
perform timely annual performance
reviews for all full-time classified
employees um finally observation number
14 on page 37 recommends that the
department ensure by annual reports are
filed as required by
Statute the appendix beginning on page
39 9 reports on the current status of
Prior audit Bings the status key on page
47 shows 12 audit bindings are fully
resolved while nine are in the process
of remediation and 10 remain unresolved
this concludes my
presentation I'd like to thank the
commissioner and the department of
Information Technology staff as well as
the department of administrative
services for their cooperation
throughout the audit and I'll now turn
the presentation over to commissioner
gulay for any comments he might have
thank you
well commissioner good morning uh
morning Mr chair members of the
committee uh my name is Dennis goule I'm
the commissioner of the Department of
Information Technology I want to start
by thanking the LBA audit staff they're
professional and thorough and and uh um
you know we we do did enjoy working with
them um so first of all I want to say
that we do care about this stuff and we
you know we're taking what we see here
seriously we've already started working
on all of these items some of them are
close to resolution or are in in process
um so I'll I'll talk about some of the
more important ones because um the the
cap 95 the allocation methodology uh
software that we're using is is
Antiquated um we we went through many
years with without um actually uh
prioritizing funding to replace that and
uh so we're in the process now of
running um we've actually been um thanks
to a capital appropriation in recent
bium where we implemented a project to
replace that system with a more modern
system that actually has the
transparency that we require for those
more complex um allocation methods the
three of 45 that were described um right
now we're running that system in
parallel um we're planning on cutting it
over at at
the the uh fiscal year boundary uh the
numbers are coming out so the the
numbers are coming out the same on the
new system as the old system right now
and it gives us confidence that our
those allocation methodologies that were
in question um can be uh can be counted
on and additionally one of the things
we've uh We've uh asked for the vendor
to help us with is providing that level
of transparency that I think has been
lacking at least for you know from my
perspective I think if you asked an
agency Finance person as well you know
you know what what's all this mean and
why is am I getting charged this amount
so so while while I um I think the the
LBA Auditors are correct in you know
when they see those methodologies and
they can't back into how that number
came about I think that's absolutely
correct uh we will be able to do that
and and I think for me the fact that
we're seeing the same allocations come
out on the new system as the old system
is builds some confidence um that that
system is also the the system is called
CAP plus it's B basically a new version
we we did a competitive procurement on
that found that cost effectively um for
us we we actually don't spend a lot of
money on our own technology it's kind of
the like the landscaper in their yard
but um in this case I think it's
important and you and we will be um you
know going live on that barring any
unforeseen things going live on that on
the uh fiscal year boundary um
so um the uh one one of the other
factors I think is and and a mitigating
factor I wanted to share is that a lot
of if you peel back the onion on a lot
of these findings what it what it comes
down to is we we may be doing
something correctly or nearly correctly
but we can't prove it through policy or
documentation and so we're a couple
years into a new program in doit where
we're completely revamping our um you
know our policies and procedures and and
and we actually assign staff to do that
staff who used to be working on you know
more not the same people but you know
authoriz positions that used to be
working on more technical stuff to to
focus on that and we've made a lot of
progress but where we we hadn't really
focused them on this particular stuff
previously we were more focused on the
federal financial audits that we were
getting which we were pretty much
continuously audited so um you know both
on the financial side as well as on the
operational cyber security uh and and um
continuity operation side so we could
share with you audit findings but our
findings from the feds have been pretty
good lately and we we will and that came
about mostly because we were focusing on
making sure we were paying attention to
and and updating our own policies and
then following them so we're going to do
that here as well we've already started
that process both on the payroll side um
as well as on the accounts payable and
some of the other stuff that was found
in this in this in these findings um and
going to um representative Edwards
concern around item six and then the
other item which was really more of a
legislative change the I think it was up
12 I think um so on 12 that's we had we
did ask James Jerry to put um some
language in House Bill too to square
that away to me that's just getting
document what how things exist today and
and so that assuming you know at some
point if it remains in house bill to and
if that passes that particular finding
will be taken care of except for one
piece which is the when doit was formed
there were people came in as classified
37 and 1 half hour people and there are
people that came in a small number of
them as 40-hour people so what we're
going to do to address that over time so
that one's going to hang out for a while
because as people retire we'll just stop
you know we won't refill that position
as a non-compliant position we'll fill
it as a compliant whatever is compliant
at that time assuming we do refill the
position um so and with respect to item
six um we're not making major mistakes
on paying people we're not making can
make major mistakes on paying out people
but what you what you can see in the in
the findings is that you have a a
separation of Duties issue there well we
got to make sure that somebody else can
say that and and there has to be a
policy and procedure that you know that
that we follow that is rigorous so that
we can prove it and that's what we're
working on in fact as soon as we saw
this we started working on that and I
expect to have that resolved soon and U
so sorry I could comment on every one of
these but I don't want to take up your
time I want you to get to ask about the
ones you're most concerned with so I'll
be quiet now and take
questions representative
lean I'd just like to Second what
Senator gray said earlier um a number of
these issues dealing with billing and
fraud issues date back to like
2006 and haven't been addressed so my
concern is we have the LBA doing this
work pointing out these issues and some
of them are holdovers from 10 years ago
so I again as Senator gray said we
should be getting on these a little
quicker than we are yes I I agree and
and there's really no excuse I won't I'm
not going to make an excuse for that I
will say we've been working on that
particular the the one cost allocation
one we've been working on that since I
joined in 2015 and things just take a
while sometimes funding and and ability
to deliver but I agree with you that you
know those the the fact that we hadn't
you know dealt with those two
2006 um audit findings which predate Me
by nine years so you know and I've been
here almost 10 now so it's a it's pretty
long time and I there's no excuse
for Senator waters for a question thank
you Mr chairman and thank you um so back
to 2006 the uh recommendation about
having memoranda of understanding with
agencies on Services um do you think
that that's necessary or is that
something that you you think should be
done done or should not be done I mean I
I so I'm concerned about what I when I
when I discuss with agencies about the
arrangements with information technology
issues come up and I I'm unclear as to
how what kind of I'll share my thoughts
on that in and so we have a an
Enterprise approach to things so we
don't want we don't generally and you
know every every agency is different and
their requirements are different so
obviously you have to take that into
account and um and again that relates
back to the federal audits which are all
potentially different based on which you
know which federal agency and and and
the agency in question who's being
audited um but with respect to a
memorandums of understanding or what we
would what I would call a service level
agreement no way in no way do I think a
service level agreement should be
different for every agency I we wouldn't
be able to do that um we run pretty lean
we don't have a big staff and um but
what what I how we operate is Baseline
plus so what we try to do is every
agency is a little different in in terms
of their tolerance for any
downtime and so structuring our service
approach with a baseline service level
agreement and then different things for
different agencies for example we have a
a 7x24 365 on call program that agencies
can choose to buy into if they want what
happens there is those folks who are on
call at any given time which include
folks who can fix network problems
system problems and other other types of
problems um are being paid for under the
terms of the collective bargain
agreement to be on call all the time and
so some agencies buy into that because
of the importance of their you know
being able to respond within a you know
really quickly at any time day or night
some don't and that's an example of a
variable service level agreement for
agencies um in the in case of some of
our other businesses like for example
you got you know Charlie from Lottery
was up here he has specific contracts
for you know the machines all around the
state that are super strict because of
the potential Revenue implications of
you know having one of those down or
more than one of those down so so um
I've resisted a you know service level
agreements or orus with each agency and
I will continue to do that um because I
don't think it's a good idea I think get
a solid Baseline and then do do um uh
you know tweaks by agency based on um
needs and then again there's a funding
issue you know I I'll be able to do what
I'm able to do based on the funding as
well so that that is a
factor representative Edwards uh thank
you Mr chair thank you uh Mr
commissioner this this is a this is
actually meant to be a helpful question
um I'm looking at page nine at The
Advisory Board and I see that the uh it
council is established under a statute
um and that it's it's meant twice in two
and a half years and it just makes me
wonder aloud and and to get your
feedback um did is this Advisory Board
actually useful uh is it adding value is
there something we should be looking at
to to to change the statute um I I'm I'm
just curious this didn't show up in a
finding but meeting twice and two an a
half years sort of flashes a red light
if that it's not quite right yeah we we
did so during Co and and for some period
of time after Co we were heads down
surviving and um and and the fact that
that
strategic body who would be if you look
prior to that on our website you'll see
that we were meeting you know two to
four times a year we were you know
generating activities including you know
multiple strategic plans and things like
that cyber security cyber security
activities uh it's a very important body
I think I think it's the overall or
should be anyway the overall governing
body for me uh to help guide what doit
is doing for the State of New Hampshire
and um so um we have we're working on
scheduling another one we're in the
process of revising our now
three-year-old strategic plan which
We'll be asking that body to help to to
ratify so um I I think um and I did
notice that um uh a senator was added to
U uh in the I think it was in the last
session uh to which I had had asked for
but had been led to believe in committee
that wouldn't happen but it looks like
it did happen I'd be you know the one
thing I would say is that having um
trying to get two house members to a
meeting is difficult so if I had four
house members on the committee then
getting two to a meeting at any given
time would be easier that's the one
thing I would potentially say but I I
like the transparency I like having the
ability to um get input both from both
the the legislature and my peers around
the department heads who are members as
well as folks from outside which
includes higher ed County government
city government and the private
sector thank
you commissioner goule you have items 11
and 12 calling for legislative
action
so if you get some proposal to to me in
the next four or five weeks I can
include it in hb2 okay so it would
become law we'll do one one of those
we've been trying to pass that was in
the performance audit we've had it we've
had language in in um and it ended up I
think a couple times in one time it was
was in an omnius bill that didn't pass
and another time um it it didn't pass
because the committee didn't like it but
um my my approach to this and I'd be
happy to chat with anybody is is you
know I don't think doit should be a
rulle making entity I think we should be
governed under under you know 21r
whatever we should be doing and and and
stick with that and that was the essence
of the language and I think that was
what the contention for on the committee
was in terms of uh cuz there's ambiguity
we we have stuff we have stuff to find
in 21r that kind of says what we should
do and then we say and then we have that
other language which I'd like to strike
which says we should be making rules and
I don't I in my opinion I don't think we
need to be making rules so we'll we'll
send language over and and thank you
very much for that offer since that
experience that you've had it turned
down have they given you good reasoning
that you can amend it to some degree
good so if you send us the proposal we
will be able to put it in HP too thank
you very much thank you further from the
committee I guess we are on record as
having uh accepted the report and placed
it on file so we don't need to make that
any further uh since it already has been
accepted thank you for your good work
hope you uh you can make progress on all
these these items that have written up
and and uh stay in touch with us as how
it goes we'll work it and keep you
updated thank you very much is there
anything further on this
audit thank you very much for your
thoroughness thank you all right we'll
move on to next
meeting suggestion from LBA sure so
historically uh fiscal has met on the
third Friday tried to meet on the third
Friday of the month that would um put
you out until February
21st Friday
are we looking at
2025 yes okay yeah the 21st 21st
yes looking on the wrong page here all
right Friday the 21st I appreciate
everybody accommodating to this Thursday
for me since I have u a long time
scheduled County meeting tomorrow on
Friday but Friday the 21st works for me
how about the rest of you
it it it works for me just as a footnote
people may want to realize that's before
the winter break not that any of us are
going to break but that's the Friday
before the winter break
y i just note that um Mr chairman uh
that is the same time as the governor's
commission Alcohol and Other Drugs which
both um represent I serve on but so it
may be on I'll try to be here as a
priority but on an occasion I may need
to substitute now what time does the
alcohol commission meet it's 9:30 to
11:30
9:30 I would also mention that the
oversight Commission on children's
services meets at 9
o' if we put it in the afternoon would
that be
better as a personal problem I think I
have HHS oversight in the afternoon but
but we'll figure it out if that's what
you decide what time you think that
would be in the afterno it starts at 1
you
know how long how long does it usually
go uh if I am not asking questions it
takes an
hour is it in this room no uh no sir no
okay you're on that as
well should we make it at two is that a
inconvenience Mr Kane I can leave it up
to the committee um Fridays are going to
be difficult
uh for fiscal just because we do also
have historically yes um you have a new
education funding committee that meets
on in the morning too I I can't say
whether or not they're going to meet
that Friday so it'll have to be a case
by case every month I don't know if at
11:00 a.m. works on Friday the 21st for
those members who have 9:30 meetings or
not um because I know there are
afternoon meetings I don't anticipate a
huge agenda in February uh which I so
shouldn't be too 11 will be good 11 11
11 y all right Friday at
11: thank you
fiscal no the next day is Washington's
birthday I know that was somewhere
around that all
right anything further I haven't seen
that thank you all for your attendance
and uh and for reading the uh the audits
F always have interesting information
always all
right finance committee is
adjourned
email you keep the
a e